shiner se benvenuti in un nuovissimo b
ci stiamo avvicinando sempre di più al
milione di iscritti e sono
emozionatissima non vedo l'ora mi
raccomando se non avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al canale come vedete qui e
cliccate sulla campanella vicino al
tasso di iscrizione
così vi arriverà una notifica tutte le
volte che pubblicherà un nuovo video
dopo il video sulle tipologie di
studenti durante le video lezioni
se non l'avete ancora visto lo lascio
qui mi avete chiesto di fare lo stesso
video ma per quanto riguarda i
professori quindi sulle tipologie di
professori durante le federazioni come
sapete un debole per quanto riguarda i
video sui prof
e quindi ho colto la palla al balzo ma
bando alle ciance e partiamo subito con
il video
[Musica]
ma io dico ma che cosa sto a perdere
tempo con questi platini che tanto
guarda non ascoltano neanche a mimì vi
sentite no parlavo con i gatti come non
mi vedete che cosa vedete ma io non ho
messo nessun tipo di zoom mi dispiace
allora se mi sentite mi vedete è
speriamo che il dio del web ce la mandi
buona questa volta ci siete vi sentite
scusate poi cappelli con mi sono appena
alzato in questi giorni di lontananza
mi mancate come l'aria non vedo l'ora di
rivedervi presto detto questo interrotto
il mou mi sentite nei ragazzi allora
adesso impero però ve lo dico subito
tutte le videocamere devono essere
accese perché sarò anche vecchia meno
solo micari bandita
ciao a tutti ragazzi come state come
state vivendo questa situazione non me
ne frega niente se la regione era alle 8
va bene sono le sette del mattino e io
voglio fare lezione e voi prendete
appunti staccate il piceno che cosa vi
dico ciao non mi vedete e ade adesso mi
vedete pronto chi siete
chi mi affido barcap lisa ragazzi perché
non vi vedo mi sembra di parlare con la
lavatrice così attivati queste
videocamere per favore mi sento sola
ragazzi da quando sono in quarantena non
mi mancate neanche un po
allora se gentilmente mi disattivate
microfoni io faccio l'appello intanto
edwin i non rispondi allora assente
simon me non importa niente se siete
appena svegli che si tengono tutti col
kabylia to fatti io voglio vedere in
faccia babini accendete tutte queste
videocamere i ragazzi di tv vedete di
vedere bene forse avevo fatto chiudere i
grifoni che tessere cioè quindi abbiamo
detto videocamere accede ai microfoni
per o disattivati e si attiva solo
quelli interrogati poi non si può
mangiare non si può bere non ci si può
alzare non ci può parlare viaggiare si
può dargli bagno ma si pone anche
respira temi sentiti e battete un colpo
che cos'è che mi state scrivendo tutti
qua nella nella chat prof non la
sentiamo certo certo ragazzi io sono
crecchi novero ragazzi non ve lo dico
più non si può mangiare né bere durante
le elezioni lo capite o no sì io sto
bevendo va bene perché gli opposti io
sono il prof
quando sarete proprio voi bere tè caffè
davanti ai vostri alunni
[Musica]
no la videocamera la potete tenere
spenta tranquillamente tanto io mi fido
di voi so che è seguita l'unica cosa se
gentilmente simeoni mela tiene accesa
con la tiber che mi gira così va bene
qualche problema attraccarsi mi dispiace
ma per oggi devo stare un po qui col
bambino perché piange tantissimo è tutto
il giorno che chi piange che urla che fa
la cacca molle
io lo so lo so che colpa vostra se non
funzionale mio cane siete dei maledetti
comunque a ragazzi più mi guardo in
videocamera più dico ma ma ma dove l'ha
trovato un'altra professoressa così è
cioè sono senza dubbio la più bella
della scuola però me lo dovete anche
dire voi datemi un po di soddisfazione a
inizio anno zero sbagliato parlare di
questo argomento quindi dovrebbe essere
qualcosa dei ragazzi scusate il mio
cagnolino non so se ve l'avevo ancora
prese in dato lui si chiama ercole amore
della mamma adesso non posso stare qua
partite koch
però se a voi non ve dà fastidio è io le
faccio due rette
così due condendo e poi se ne va va bene
berna vitucci ha veramente la ballata è
perché non ci fai un nome tour
bene allora interroghiamo facciamo così
chiedo google ok google
scegli un numero da 1 a 23 io non riesco
a capire perchè non mi vedono antonio ma
io ho acceso la videocamera allora
adesso intergato è voi potete scegliere
o chiudete gli occhi così noleggiata
oppure volete tenervi occhi aperti
indietro vi mettete un bello specchio di
uno specchio avete sentito bene a casa
ce l'abbiamo tutti uno specchio che lo
mettete dietro così bello se davanti
avete il liber ragazzo io non ve lo dico
più dovete iscrivervi subito al canale
di marino per cascina ovi boccio tutti
quanti proprio uno dopo l'altro questo
questo il mio preferito è il mio peluche
proprio che lo amo tantissimo più delle
cotolette attacchi totti dalla video
lezioni non mi voglio più vedere sentire
e in ogni fede dei led e rispettosi
maleducati perché non ascoltate lo fate
niente quindi sta in guarda guarda il
dito spendo vengo vengono a noi
riprendiamo ad ora arrivati si si avete
visto bene io e la telecamera la tengo
spenta perché mi ha detto mia figlia che
poi mi fate le meme quelle robe lì su
internet bravi bravi sfotte temi poi mi
diverto io fine anno è visto che le
altre volte mi avevate chiesto di farli
vedere una mia foto da giovane eccola
questa qua e la mia foto con il mio
primo fidanzato
ero a venezia avevo i capelli castani
perché adesso purtroppo ma avete
scoperta a me me tingo i capelli
io in realtà so di questo colore quano
potevo fare la modella a dire la verità
però per far contento mi padre ne son
filata dentro il mondo dell'istruzione
ti rimanga era di noi ragazzi ho seguito
il vostro consiglio mi sono scaricati in
the è che dire due tematiche ho trovati
chi commenta alla fine della prima
guerra mondiale la situazione era una
situazione
scusate un attimo
carmen no non mi visto in via fatto a
mora anzi guarda meno male più come fare
ciò massimo bianchi a tenervi il toso
qui dai sto facendo lezione mi sto
facendo una figura di cacca
a proposito devo aver toccato qualcosa
perché adesso non va più il microfono
più ma siccome non riesco più sono
proprio contenta che mi vedete meno male
abbiamo anche una supremazia del colore
a rispetto al disegno scusate un attimo
devo togliere la pasta al forno perché
se no qua brucia tutto arriva ragazzi
veramente scusate ma è una situazione un
po e cercate di capirmi sono mamma da
poco e devo gestire tutte le cose io
guarda un po dove pensi di essere a casa
tua
ragazzi ma mi sentite da te vincendo un
segno qualcosa mi sentite o no che dire
ah sì ho spiegato tutto troppo in fretta
sono passati solo 20 minuti però la
lezione la stella che è finita quindi
buona giornata ragazzi ci si vede domani
la riesch a monte non mi devi rompere le
balle sto facendo lezione
vai a giocare con la mamma allora
studiate da qua a qua più o meno dei
letti da questo paragrafo qui già buona
vita ci vediamo già tolto gliela pasta
al forno però almeno può pulire un po
passare l'aspirapolvere io vedi che
fanno occupata forma risparmi capire tua
casa può disegni sui tavoli squisiti un
attimo che devo aprire le porte del cane
ercole amore dallera attimo arrivo
allora ragazzi facciamo così c'è una
bella giornata me ne voglio andare sul
balcone la provincia
quindi lascio i compiti e chi s'è visto
s'è visto inizia a esserci molto
interesse verso l'arte esotica quindi
soprattutto quella cinese
quindi che cosa succeda vita mia vita
mia
adesso basta perché la mamma sta
lavorando se non la smetti tele tre anni
va bene basta basta non sa più cosa
spiega non è anche doria ciao
facciamo così fate tutti gli esercizi da
pagina 126 a pagina 197 è così rimanete
allenati no adesso mi sentite vero ma i
fatti mi sembrava sono presenti alcuni
tekken e tekken e street band
non so più come dirvelo non vi voglio
sentire il battito della distruzione del
colonia di leader e della della
modernità di quello che chiedo allora se
vuoi che vada un po più piano e per
questo mi sa un po pacino per rendere
stampa andando veloce se vuoi che vede
vi piano
vai doppio piano ok la regione di tipo
igienico più di niente niente minute
mica tanto mariga roma che però dice che
era di liverpool minime
basta ragazzi la lezione è finita ci
vediamo domani e studiate fate i compiti
un bacione no ma guarda ma veramente ma
io non so non li sopporto più questi
sono dei cretini cioè io spiego non mi
ascoltano il rispettati proprio ma
quando mi è venuto in mente di fare
questo lavoro
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto e che abbia fatto ridere mi
raccomando commentate qui sotto
facendomi saperi sommati in quali di
queste tipologie e avete rivisto i
vostri professori seguitemi anche su
instagram sui tic toc perché ultimamente
sto postando tantissimi contenuti anche
vi mando un bacione norme e ci vediamo
al prossimo
io adoro ciao ciao